i think social interaction is the number
one important thing that a child can
have in their life
is that they need social interaction
constantly so
i think something and whether it's
martial arts or whether it's something
different is having that connection with
other kids their age is
you know the first step to social
development for children is learning how
to greet people
and they come in here and i see them get
so excited to greet their friends and
they greet other family members
from other parents in the school and
it's just it's an amazing environment
and allowing them to come here
and to just be themselves and then they
have the knowledge of self-defense
and knowing self-awareness of what's
happening around you and what you're
doing
and it can help keep them safe and then
they just learn to be a role model for
others the martial art is called
taekwondo
okay and it's um just the way of the
hand and the foot
and then we blend other styles of
martial arts into our prog
or into our program to create a
well-rounded martial artist as we also
teach self-defense that comes from our
krav maga
program and the style of krav maga is
very realistic and practical
self-defense so they learn the
discipline and technique and structure
of taekwondo the discipline changes so
much and that's what i tell parents
constantly too is i have years
to help their child become a phenomenal
martial artist
i have days and weeks and maybe at the
longest months
to impact their life and teach them how
to behave like a martial artist and to
feel like a martial artist and it's so
exciting
when you see your child take their first
class and they stand like this
and then they go and a year later and
they're interacting with somebody
different and they're standing like this
when they're speaking to somebody
you just see that discipline grow so
much it helped me
a lot when i was little like in about
first grade i was bullied really bad
and i went i was kind of in a dark place
and i went through therapy
and i got like professional help and
none of that really helped
and then i came to victory and i met mr
chambers and he pretty much
changed my life my self-esteem was very
low and i never really
i didn't have any friends and i feel
like being here
boosted my confidence because getting up
in front of the class and
like teaching a class or like helping
someone during class that helped my
confidence
and then that also helped me in school
because um
just like instead of walking with my
head down i'd walk with my head up
instead of like
letting somebody pick on me i'd use my
words or
like i'd go to a teacher instead of just
letting it happen
i'm a second degree black belt and i'm a
state champion xma weapons
and then i'm world ranked and sparring
and i'm planning on going to worlds this
year